[Music]
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
he just continues to prove that he is
completely incompetent and incapable of
enacting president Trump's agenda now
just last month McConnell complained and
whined that the president had excessive
expectations really what's this and now
according to roll call McConnell is
actually saying the tax reform may have
to wait until next year I don't know
about you watching at home but I have
literally had it up to here and beyond
with Mitch McConnell now the only thing
this guy does is come up with excuse
after excuse after excuse as to why he
can't keep the simple promises that he
and others made to you the American
people now he has said for over seven
years he was going to repeal replace
Obamacare and then when he gets the
chance he blows it and now McConnell is
saying tax reform will have to wait
until 2018
it is beyond unacceptable and it really
shows you why Senator McConnell has the
pathetic 18% approval rating in his home
state of Kentucky
now McConnell is not leading he's not
getting the job done so senator if you
don't want to roll up your sleeves if
you don't want to get to work on passing
the agenda you promised the president
promised then maybe it's time to call it
a career get out of the way let someone
else who actually cares about keeping
their promises to the American people
let them step up let then start passing
legislation now also tonight Hillary
Clinton released her book it's called
what happened and by the way was all
smiles earlier today while kicking off
the first part of a book tour signing
copies right here in New York City but
tonight Clinton should be anything but
happy because this book and I media will
tell you is full of nothing but excuses
lies and to use a phrase fake news now
crooked Hillary is the president calls
her is in complete denial about why she
actually lost this election now let's
take a listen at the long list of
Clinton excuses that our colleague and
friend Greg Jarrod has put together look
at this
Clinton is up to now given 32 reasons
for why she lost
the list grows and grows and grows and
no person no thing is spared now Clinton
is blamed everyone and everything but
herself and her terrible campaign for
this defeat now Gregg Jarrett he's going
to join us along with Jay Sekulow with
reaction but instead of writing a
tell-all book Clinton could have saved
herself a lot of time and just take a
long look in the mirror but of course
this is Hillary Clinton we're talking
about
she'll never pass up an opportunity a to
make money and be cast blame on others
it's exactly what Hillary Clinton did in
an interview with CBS this weekend just
take a look at this analysts who I have
a great deal of respect for like Nate
silver burrowed into all the data and
said but for that Comey letter she would
have won but even though that was the
primary blow to my campaign at the very
end I it has to be looked at in context
with the Russians weaponizing
information negative stories about me
this whole WikiLeaks beginning to leak
in early October of John Podesta Z mails
Facebook was taking money from Russian
companies to run negative stories about
me and then let's not forget sexism and
misogyny which are endemic to our
society misogyny the last one now these
examples are just the tip of the iceberg
when it comes to Clinton blaming others
for why it is that she lost Allen in
this new book Hillary actually
criticizes the liberal mainstream media
for all the scandals surrounding the
Clinton Foundation now listen to this I
knew from experience that if I ran for
president again everything bill and I
had ever touched would be subject to
scrutiny and attack including the
foundation that was a concern but I
never imagined that this widely
respected global charity would be as
savagely smeared and attacked as it was
during the campaign there was twice as
much written about the Clinton
Foundation as there was on any of the
Trump scandals she's not painting
herself as the victim she's completely
out of touch let's set the record
straight let's give you the truth she's
out of touch with the facts
surrounding the Clinton Foundation now
take a look at the side of the screen
the Clinton Foundation took millions and
millions of dollars from countries like
Saudi Arabia Kuwait the UAE and others
you know countries that treat women gays
lesbians Christians and Jews horribly
Saudi Arabia remember women can't drive
they need permission to work or to
travel marital rape in these countries
and many of them is not recognized if
you're gay or lesbian many of those
countries the punishment is death and by
the way you're not allowed to build a
church or temple in Saudi Arabia for
example that would be illegal and that's
just the one country of the many that
the Clintons have taken money from not
to mention all the allegations of pay to
play at the Clinton Foundation you may
remember back in August of last year
when the AP published a story with the
headline quote many donors to Clinton
Foundation met with her at state and the
report details quote more than half the
people outside the government who met
with Hillary Clinton while she was
Secretary of State gave money either
personally or through companies or
groups to the Clinton Foundation wow you
donate you get a meeting and then of
course the uranium one deal as her
tenure as Secretary of State Hillary
Clinton she was one of nine people to
approve the transfer of up to 20% of
America's uranium you know the
foundational material for nuclear
weapons
to who Vladimir Putin the Russians Wow
there is a real conspiracy and then
people involved in that deal ended up
kicking back as much as a hundred and
forty five million dollars to the
Clinton Foundation oh and Bill Clinton
doubled his speaking fees in Moscow so
sorry Hillary Clinton the media
Republicans they're not to blame for all
the corruption at the Clinton Foundation
and by the way you and your husband are
and next of course Hillary's excuse for
her email server scandal in her book
what happened she actually attacks the
New York Times the New York Times
over their coverage blaming them listen
to this The Times as usual played an
outsized role in shaping the coverage of
my emails throughout the election to me
the papers approached felt schizophrenic
it spent nearly two years beating me up
about emails but it's glow
endorsement applied some sanity to the
controversy then in the homestretch of
the race when it mattered most the paper
went right back to its old ways all
right again let's tell the truth and
let's set the record straight that's
laughable because remember WikiLeaks
exposed the New York Times is only one
of the many mainstream media outlets
interestingly enough except the Fox News
Channel that was caught red-handed they
were colluding with the Clinton campaign
now the reason her emails became such a
big story is because Clinton broke
several laws remember she had secret top
secret special access program and
classified information on her server
you know the server stored in the
bathroom of a mom-and-pop shop now the
FBI also told us that it's likely that
up to five foreign intelligence agencies
gained access to every single classified
email and every special access program
email on that server and it even gets
worse remember Clinton's team deleted
33,000 emails using bleach pit in other
words acid wash after being served with
the congressional subpoena now an aide
also smashed those old mobile devices
with a hammer we can't get the emails
from there and then to top it all off
members of Clinton's legal team remember
if they did get the FBI blackberries but
those blackberries didn't have SIM cards
in them Rendy rendering them meaningless
now there's also the fact that Clinton
changed the story and lied every step of
the way when it came to her use of a
private email server now this is all
pathetic and Clinton is delusional the
media won't tell you she can't come to
grips with the reality she was a
terrible candidate no message no vision
for the American people and by the way
she didn't even bother to campaign in
swing states like Wisconsin Michigan
Pennsylvania